good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP
1919 object class
uclid special containment procedures a
Zone with a radius of 2 km must be
maintained surrounding scp1 1919 any
roads or paths leading to the building
are to be diverted or obstructed the
perimeter of this zone is to be guarded
by a set of no fewer than 40 previously
25 heavily armed and armored patrolman
those entering scp1 1919 shall not be
given body armor or Weaponry any
presence within the perimeter that is
not confirmed to be a member of an
expedition team is to be terminated and
immediately the official report
concerning Expedition 3 is to be
accessed only by those currently
researching SCP
1919 and those present for the incident
itself all copies of the report have
been destroyed revised as of expedition
2 under no circumstances is anyone to be
allowed entry into scp1
1919 until all identified manifestations
of scp1
19191 pertinent to the previous entrance
or entrance have been eliminated or
until such time has elapsed that all
manifestations can be expected to have
starved to
death description scp1 1919 is an early
20th century hotel and converted Mansion
located in as of expedition 3 the
building has sunk partially into the
ground on the Eastern side it is still
traversable but additional safety
precautions are necessary from the
outside scp1 1919 looks much as it did
when it was first built on the inside
however the building is massively
decrepit and looks like it has been
abandoned since its creation many
floorboards and ceilings are rotten or
absent entirely and various forms of
damage EG water damage collaps debris
cover much of the Interior entry of the
hotel by human results in the appearance
of a number of humanoid beings
throughout the building resembling the
subject and wearing and carrying
anything the subject possesses with them
on arrival these creatures collectively
labeled scp1 19191 typically vary from
the original in several physical aspects
observed variations between subjects and
counterparts include the following lack
of Bonnie hair misshaping cranial
structure patches of skin
discoloration variance in limb or digit
length disfigurement of the mouth sealed
or missing eyelids sealed
nostrils perforations of various sizes
in skin elongated or deformed jaw
structure scp1 19191 is responsible for
the decrepit state of the building
individuals have been recorded upending
Furniture tearing out floorboards
damaging pipes and otherwise causing
small scale
destruction the fact that they are
capable of this makes the reason why to
date only three have attempted to escape
the building
unclear all observed creatures labeled
scp1
19191 have behaved in a similar manner
individually they act aggressively with
or without provocation attempting to
damage objects and structures at random
they also demonstrate a marked increase
in hostility once they locate the
subject or subjects who enter scp1 1919
the Expedition logs 1 and two this
behavior however seems not to extend to
to each other rather they are
predisposed to form large coordinated
groups upon encountering more of their
kind the largest observed group thus far
contains members and was responsible for
incapacitating task force to 11 youth
hostiles as a whole scp1 19191 exhibits
a swarm intelligence akin to that of an
ant colony it is yet unknown
specifically how they communicate but
they have proven to be able to do so
quickly and not verbally while
unverified as a all signs point to scp1
19191 possessing an organ system that
allows it to send and receive signals
via pheromones the fact that killing or
wounding one even noiselessly and out of
the presence of others attracts all
within an estimated 40 m radius directly
toward the one that harmed corroborates
this addendum 1919
01 Expedition 3 saw SCP
19191 cause only one immediate fatality
among mobile task force to 11 the rest
of the task force was disfigured in many
of the same ways as their duplicates
video footage suggests that this change
in Behavior was deliberate and not the
result of successful self-defense the
majority of mobile task force to 11
succumbed to their injuries within a
week of leaving the building despite
sustaining severe damage to the lower
jaw was reported by medical staff to
have repe heed the phrase in the picture
intermittently before falling
unconscious another died on route to
Foundation treatment
facilities addendum 1919 2 after
analyzing footage from Expedition 3 it
has come to the foundation's attention
that a being located inside the building
is responsible for the creation of all
observed instances of SCP
19191 the new primary objective of all
efforts concerning the SCP is the
identification retrieval and containment
of said being in confronting her
researchers are instructed
to Expedition log 1 D7 D7 2274 Caucasian
male age 39 C1 Dr limitz Communications
relay
site
t11 former head mobile task force to 11
youth hostiles playing log
now what are you doing the front door
not opening it was either locked or
stuck couldn't move in an inch the
windows I tried weren't working either
and I don't want to break any of them
before I even get
inside try the side entrance or the back
if that doesn't work all right D7 2274
spends the next 3 minutes walking around
to the side of the house scanning his
surroundings with his flashlight when he
arrives at the main West an entrance he
pulls the handle and the door opens
looks like we're in luck think the place
is air conditioned D7 2274 closes the
door to scp1 1919 behind him as it
clicks shut the microphone either picks
up or generates a high-pitched whistle
that quickly Fain are you hearing that
what's that noise what noise all I'm
hearing is my own Footsteps in here it's
stopped disregard it and proceed not
sure what a disregarding but okay I
guess the beam of the flashlight lands
on an assortment of dismantled and
dilapidated pieces of furniture before a
lighting on a tattered portrait of a
young red-haired woman much of the
canvas has been shredded including the
majority of the woman's face the missing
pieces are not seen move in nearer to
the painting please I want to see
something shallow grooves are visible on
the surface of the wall they cover much
of it Crossing each other in rows of
three or four
you seeing these scratches they're all
over the place in here Floor Walls parts
of the ceiling they almost look like
he rounds a corner and audibly
presses his back to the wall what's
wrong the flashlight is suddenly
extinguished d722 74s breathing can be
heard to increase in speed what's
happening why did you turn your
flashlight off I don't think I'm alone
in here why not did you see somebody
some something like that he slowly leans
the camera around the corner at the end
of the long hallway is a beam of light
bobbing erratically and switching on an
off at odd intervals there is a faint
sound of labored breathing not coming
from D7
2274 what should I do who could that
possibly be you guys have armed guards
outside right they couldn't have gotten
in here within the past it's not
recommended that you approach him it
your current priority is now to evacuate
the the microphone can be heard being
forced out of Dr litz's grasp disregard
previous instruction if what you saw is
part of the SCP which we can suspect it
is you are obligated to investigate it
stay at a safe distance and get it on
video you have no right proceed it might
just be some teenagers getting high or
something anyway d 72274 stands up and
looks into the other hallway again the
flashlight has disappeared and the sound
of breathing from seconds before has
gone faint the declass takes a tentative
step into the corridor we can't see
anything D7 2274 makes no indication of
having heard please turn on your
flashlight there is no response D
72274 you are ordered to turn on your
flashlight the light immediately lands
on a bright orange fabric causing the
camera's contrast settings to obscure
the video no D7 7 2274 starts to run
switching his light off what was that
what did you see I don't I why are you
running what are you running from answer
me it was me I don't it was me what what
do you mean the declass trips over
something in the dark falling forward
and dropping the video camera so that it
points down the hall towards his unseen
follower footsteps approach him from
behind he turns himself over SC
scambling away on his back while facing
whatever it is pursuing him no no no no
no what's going on stand up get out of
there can you move a beam of light
illuminates D7 2274 from the end of the
hallway he has not reached a second one
follows it and then a third all three
shake and flicker as more footfalls
approach the camera D7 2274 begins
screaming as the lights pass over him
they land upon an orange jumpsuit and a
a malformed hand before a face comes
into view it vaguely resembles D7
2274 but its eyelids look to be missing
and its lips are fused together and set
at a bizarre angle leave the camera
running sounds of tearing begin from
behind the camera the screaming stops
after 2 hours and 26 minutes the camera
is picked up and moved to another room
where it is thrown onto the floor with
Force sufficient to break
it
and
log Expedition log 2 D3 d381 38
Caucasian male 27 D4 D40 076 Caucasian
male 22 D9 D9
0124 African-American male age
36 C1 Dr limitz Communications relay
site play log now
now note for this procedure video
cameras have been sewn into the clothing
worn by all 3D class to leave their
hands available protocol requires me to
remind you that if you try anything at
all out of line with what the foundation
and its Representatives request that you
are to be terminated immediately but I'm
sure you already knew that yeah you
don't take it so lightly the people
guarding this place have weapons much
more powerful than the ones we have to
give you and they won't hesitate to
right look nobody's doing anything unto
Ward okay so would you mind not saying
the same over and over for the rest
of this trip I don't take that kind of
insolence for my own subordinates 90124
don't speak to me that way again I hear
you doc how are we getting into this
place can't remember he'll be taking the
Western entrance our last man didn't get
very far so you'll more or less be
picking up where he left off no
sounds great nice and safe that's why
we've got guns dumbass oh speaking of
which remember that you are permitted to
fire your weapons only at anything
inside the house that looks like the man
whose picture you were shown before you
left he'll be dressed the same as you
three so be sure not to mistake him for
one of you or vice versa you phrased
that differently before we left what
does that mean anything that looks like
him oh you're encouraging us to murder
somebody if it happens it won't be
murder interesting conversation pauses
for 15 seconds as the d-class approached
the West entrance you want to kick the
door in or should I don't advertise your
presence any more than you can help your
priority here is helping us gather
intelligence you're not an extermination
Squad fine can we go inside at least or
burning daylight I don't want to be here
when the sun sets you may enter remain
quiet Western entrance opens D3 8138
steps into the doorway but quickly
Springs backward what the hell a
manifestation of scp1
19191 appearing as a misshapen version
of d722 74 bursts through the doorway
its right arm is approximately 1.4 times
its proportionate size in addition to
being visibly double-jointed
manifestation lung es into the sunlight
toward D
40076 who can be heard shouting until D
90124 fires his weapon once into the
creature's head killing it d381 138
clutches his ears Christ what the was
that did you know that was going to be
in there yes be on the lookout for more
of them inside more how many are there
please enter the building how many more
of these mother are waiting for us you
have been ordered to enter the building
failure to comply will result of course
don't bother doc I hear you D 90124
stops to stare at the dead manifestation
mumbling as D 38138 reopens the Western
door scp1 1991's jaw hangs several
inches lower than that of an average
human anything that looks like him Jesus
could have said something D 4076 can be
heard swearing order for the next
several seconds as all 3 declass enter
scp1 1919 as the door closes a high
frequency noise emanates from the
microphones what's our plan are we
supposed to split up yeah let's split up
great idea let's make ourselves as
vulnerable as we can well okay dick how
about you think of something survival
sound good stop talking did any of you
hear a high-pitched sound just now I
hear one every time this little teenage
ass wife op his mouth you never mind
keep moving all three camera feeds
display parts of the hallway D 72274
investigated the portrait from 2 days
previous is now almost wholly missing
and pieces of the wall beside it are
scattered across the floor what happened
in here D
90124 turns to face the corridor where
D7 2274 fell the body is absent red
streaks lead around a corner from where
he collapsed into a darkened room hey
we're walking I'm not going to yell for
you I'm coming declass reached the end
of the hallway to the right is a door
with the word Ballroom embossed on a
bronze plaque they look at each other
before pulling it open sunlight hardly
reaches the room Illuminating only a
small triangle in the doorway you have
flashlights right we can't see a thing
from here turn them on the room looks as
though it has been recently gutted most
of the floor space is unoccupied and it
can be seen easily where pictures in
large frames used to hang on the three
walls that remain intact the Southern
Wall is full of massive holes from the
Viewpoint afforded by the d-class where
the spaces in the far off wall lead to
cannot be seen it did not look this bad
from outside one or more of you take a
look at the South Wall seems unusual
we'll go over in a minute there's some
over here check it out what have
you found cameras a ton of them D
90124 points at 17 video cameras spread
halfhazard across the torn up hardwood
in the Southeastern corner of the
chamber D40 76 remains facing the South
Wall as movement within it becomes
apparent oh no where do you think these
came from the ones without crap screens
look brand new not just the first class
you need to Jesus Christ keep quiet
what's wrong with you the wall the wall
D 4076 turns and runs out of the
ballroom d912 4's camera and flashlight
point at the Southern Wall scp1 19191
begins to emerge head first from two of
the gaps in it the first manifestation
on the left looks to be the first one
that caught d722 74 but the leading one
on the right aside from a sizable dent
in the forehead Bears a close
resemblance to
d924 they land on their feet and begin
to run with considerable speed towards
the declass disregard previous
instructions leave the room immediately
seek shelter go d 90124 stands
motionless D 38138 fires his weapon into
the chests of the two duplicates
expending four rounds total a brief
metallic rattle comes from the floor
besid where the false d-class lands face
down move d381 38 grabs d 90124 by the
upper arm and pulls him toward the door
as he turns d901 124's camera captures
movement visible in 14 holes in the wall
this is
limit
password requesting immediate full
perimeter lock down D 4076 can be seen
retracing his path to the Western
entrance blocking the door to the
outside is a crowd of doppelgangers of
himself and the other declass one in the
shape of D 90124 raises his arm
displaying a pistol identical to the
ones provided by the foundation D
4076 faces the other direction and
starts to run down the corridor a series
of gunshots are heard after the third D
4076 spins and collapses camera focuses
solely on Western doorway until battery
drains there have got to be some stairs
in here the building's got at least
three floors I could see before we came
in where the D 38138 and D
90124 Sprint up a crumpled flight of
steps to the second floor and are met
with a large contingent of scp1 19191 D
90124 begins to reach for his weapon but
instead follows d381 38 up the remaining
stairs to the third story as they reach
the top floor the microphone phones
begin to whine in the same way that they
did when the Western door closed turn
the volume down I can't hear myself
think can the two of you really not hear
that are the microphones the only things
picking it up I don't have a goddamn
clue what you're talking about doctor it
sounds like feedback almost or a
dentist's drill it's deafening on this
end not right now don't bother me with
that there's something weird up here you
feel that too what is it strange feeling
kind of we should get out of here
probably both subjects move deeper into
the darkness of the hallway their
flashlights out of camera view it's
getting louder and louder where are you
going turn on a light one of you hush
answer the question you are being given
a direct order keep quiet what keep
quiet she can hear you d381 38 and D9
0124 do not acknowledge any further
communication their cameras pick up a
faint white glow from beneath one of the
closed doors in the corridor toward
which the two are moving
90124 respond
38138 the door opens and the light on
the other side becomes visibly brighter
the two cameras pick up several frames
of a female human silhouette moving
quickly in their Direction before
cutting to static for the remainder of
the battery life concurrently the camera
attached to to D 4076 picks up an
unusual sound in addition to the pitch
noted by Dr
limt headphones
recommended
still frames from cameras D
90124 and d381 38 pending
declassification and
log Expedition log three you do not have
permission to view this
file this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran B sip o crop guy James Saba
Irish
wristwatch Lost Boy
segnar your local Foundation agent
zazaon worthy fire
copster Dean
Dingus that loser bred peit Ruan
O'Brien
grimnir extra moments
123 Swift raw U malas Big Booty Judy
Desmond K and oscuro
vision if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well visit at
patreon.com slthe vulgan thank
[Music]
you